tomorrow is a monumental moment in
American history Juneteenth various
networks will have special programming
the NFL has even made it an official
company holiday but for those of you you
don't know exactly what Juneteenth is
the stars are here to help
everybody's representatives st.
Patrick's Day Columbus big Cinco de Mai
was about UT June 19 1865 or June tink
is the day in America we're all slaves
were finally free I feel like this is
going to be the biggest gym team that
we've ever seen in the United States of
America and people are gonna celebrate
it in many different ways
[Music]
155 years later this celebration of
freedom is tempered by protests for
racial equality Anthony Anderson has
been on the frontlines of that fight
inspiring crowds continues and justice
black-ish devoted an entire episode to
june team the powerful history lesson
premiered three years ago and recently
read railroads Wall Street the White
House and university you know the
saddest thing was watching the kids on
blackish come out of their dressing
rooms with slave clothes oh yeah
we are educated and people are now
sitting around the dinner table and
having these discussions after they've
watched blackish the show that returns
to ABC for seventh season this fall has
a history of using humor to tackle tough
sometimes even risky topics all in the
hopes of making a difference we are in
Sherman Oaks where it's illegal to
jaywalk and illegal to scared the
Caucasians good evening officer
I just wanna let you know that I'll be
videotaping tonight black lives matter
button I trust the tone of our show and
I really trust what we're doing and the
exploration of how we take these very
heavy hot-button important issues and
look at them through the lens of this
family as a culture we can't be afraid
to have these conversations there's
always a topic to debate in in our
family here and know that's that's why
we created this show you know to spark
the conversation that may create change
some place you think we're free your
tone makes me feel this is a trick
question
[Music]